[Applause]
well jenny we have some style news you
know weddings are evolving and brides
reports makeup isn't just for brides
anymore now grooms like to get gussied
up too hi
makeup artists they say grooms are
grooming more than ever from pre-wedding
day skin care with a good facial to some
makeup touches on the big day like a
little clear mascara on your upper lash
or flesh tone eyeliner on the water line
make the groom look energized
jenny i know that you and donnie you
renew your vows every single year right
every single year yes
romantic
it's so great because you get to
reconfirm our love and remind each other
you know of the importance the the that
the rules but the the mandate of love
that we you know promised each other but
does he wear makeup that was my question
on our wedding of course you know he's
in the business but he's more of like a
deficit kind of makeup guy and this is
where guys can get away with it like for
instance he always says i don't have any
eyebrows
and he really doesn't have any eyebrows
so he will actually use some eyebrow
filler and i'm totally fine with it so
the good bad and the ugly is i'm fine
with guys wearing it as long as they
don't steal your makeup as long as i
think guys don't put on like mascara and
like eyeliner i feel like that gets a
little rockery unless you're in a band
um but why not it's a wedding day they
should also feel pretty too you know i'd
love to see a show of hands from the men
in the audience
raise of hands how many of you would
like to be able to
just do a little grooming a little
manscaping a little
thank you
oh there's there's wives holding up
husbands thank you
yes thank you for that
well i just you know if it's there
gentlemen use it right i'm not talking
about a full lip and a blue eyeshadow
but if you got a little blemish you're a
fool if you don't cover it on your big
day okay
i think
i believe
and i do believe we're in you know a
time where it's so much more than ever
anything goes however
i do think that everybody
it's the same as you could say getting
dressed you know putting on something
that makes you feel a little peacocky
rather than a little dowdy i think it's
all you know part and parcel with just
wanting to
present yourself with a little more
confidence and and feeling good you know
what i say get the voices out of your
head do whatever it takes for you to get
out of your own crap and on to bigger
things
yes
it's your wedding day too those pictures
are going to last forever you're gonna
have to look at those wedding photos
every single time you pass your
fireplace yes
let me ask the gentleman out there you
know if your 1962 firebird convertible
was getting married and i had a nick on
the fender wouldn't you just put a
little paint on it yes you would
like you would treat your prized
possession thank you very much
[Music]
you